happy school choice week choice is a
good thing but in much of America
students don't have much choice
kids are assigned schools by zip code
and then many of those schools teach
kids that America's terrible and
capitalism hurts people so I started a
charity that offers teachers free videos
that introduce kids to free market ideas
it should be in more classrooms just to
sparked my conversation these young
people watch the videos in high school
because this teacher downloaded them
from our website and played them in
class they were amazing they really
opened up my mind to think differently
it changed the way that I viewed the
world when I originally went to school
it was all taught from one side this
country is horrible because you're a
minority you can't make it it made me
dislike the country initially then he
watched the videos this woman who came
here from Greece says America doesn't
pressure you to follow a kind of living
people can express themselves be
wherever they want to be America is a
place where we get to write the script
of our own lives when these videos were
shown to me I felt ashamed for what I
initially believed Gabriel then enlisted
in the National Guard I wanted to give
back to not only giving my family so
much opportunity but also to protect
defend and serve the people the United
States the only Perez said watching our
videos made him want to take
responsibility for himself I mean
everybody thought like this before
you know we're taught that the
government is they're responsible for us
and they're you know where we're gonna
trust them in doing everything for us so
he started his own business
welcome to familia motor good to have an
auto leasing companies receive your
brand new vehicle and
doorstep I definitely think the stossel
videos kind of helped me become more of
the entrepreneur just do the work you
know it's just being dependent don't
expect anyone to do anything for you
don't expect any handouts just get it
done many students had never heard that
competition and markets could be useful
I wasn't really exposed to any of those
ideas I never saw it before I never
heard about like this side of them the
stories 800 million people out of
poverty in Southeast Asia because
they've implemented a little bit of
capitalism if I'm wrong about this what
else am I wrong about the videos come
with teachers guides full-length
classroom lessons with discussion
questions and writing assignments even
if people disagree with the video that's
kind of good to talk about soon after a
year of watching the videos students
tell us certain ideas stuck with them
one was unintended consequences that the
government will try to do things to make
the make it beneficial to the public but
it turns out it actually made things
much worse for example you did a piece
about minimum wage and how increasing it
would supposedly be better for young
working-class people but it turned out
the unintended consequences were minimum
wage increased priced out young people
from getting jobs into the market other
students were surprised at how hard it
is the start of business in America do
you have a license Stossel goes over to
hong kong and he gets a license in just
two hours
thank you sure rather than over here it
takes months and even years I know the
struggle that my parent has to go
through to open their business so that
was kind of the training turning point
for me one particular video that really
piqued my interest was the evil rich the
top 1% people really think that the 1%
is evil because they make so much money
but the video explains the rich could
only get rich by inventing better things
things we want if it wasn't for Steve
Jobs like creating these iPhones are
creating like the Mac computers or the
Mac laptops our life would not be as
easy as it is today this is one of the
most incoherent things about their
regimes for example this video called
death by socialism it contradicts all
these like beliefs of how socialism is
great and how it helps like
the poor and all that and it kind of
showed us like oh it's not really that
great after watching in class many
students share what they learned I went
to my mom and I was like do you know
who's really paying for that all this
government stuff every time I talk to my
friends none we bring up anything about
politics I bring up this new idea that I
learned on a star sous-vide and they'd
be like really like I've never known
that 10 million students now discuss
these videos in class like you said on
it any consequences good like for
example the government how do you give
people welfare why video isn't a
textbook enough a lot of people well at
least my age group they don't like to
read and analyze they prefer to watch
videos so now our charity helps explain
free markets to students who rarely hear
about that in schools school choice
doesn't only mean where you go to school
it also means what you get to learn an
education choice doesn't have to end
with school even now that I graduated
high school I'm not watching style in
the classroom there but I'm watching
Stossel at home get out of my life